so have you noticed they're no longer
talking about Ukraine Russia that much
and by the way if you listen to the
mainstream media Ukraine is crushing
Russia like oh my God the war is already
over with Putin is begging for them to
stop that's how the mainstream media is
selling it and if you look at New York
Times story August 2023 there's a story
that came out saying 500,000 people have
died 300,000 from Russia 200,000 from
Ukraine but then if you read a story
from Zero Hedge it'll say 400,000 people
have died from Ukraine and on top of
that very interesting thing that Ukraine
did they have roughly 2 million soldiers
at the beginning of the war there's
claims that they've lost already 500,000
soldiers and according to military
Chronicle Ukrainian authorities will
soon be able to bury about 1 and A5
million people why so here's a country
that's got roughly 37 million people
living there you have 2 million soldiers
you're going against Russia you're
getting money you hundreds of billions
of dollars of money you're coming around
the greatest beggar of all time zalinsky
the greatest fundraiser of all time
zinski whatever category you want to put
him in but you do $1.5 million and then
Janet Yellen who is supposed to know
economy and money and numbers of what
America can afford comes out and says
America can certainly afford to stand
with Israel and to support Israel's
military needs and we also can and must
support Ukraine in its struggle against
Russia yell and said adding that the US
economy is doing extremely well so so
based on that quote one would say what
Janet Yellen is saying as long as you
got money you're going to be able to do
you know and fight the warant we can do
both but no no problem great I have
money I'm about to potentially buy 15
acres of land here just because I have
15 acres of land that I buy with money
does it mean day one I can go into work
in the office no I got to build the 15
acres of land into our headquarters how
long is that going to take 18 months 24
months permits you know all this other
supplies that I got to get so watch what
this other person who's a president of
roughly an 8 billion dollar company
that's in the uh industry of selling
weapons said here's Eric Lee a 30-year
kbur veteran who is a president of the
company's defense unit on November said
the following when he was torn a factory
he said I've never seen anywhere near so
much demand of people wanting to order
product what do you mean you've never
seen so much demand and by the way
what's interesting about this is new
customers though will have to wait
according to what he's saying it'll take
two years to make one of these surface
air missiles and there's already a
multi-year backlog so 2 years if you're
the first customer if you're not it's
multi-year which may take four five six
years to get them and even a bipartisan
organization in America that gets money
from a bunch of different people
including 25% of the money from the
government did a simulation a war game
simulation published in early 2023 of
how the US would respond to a Chinese
invasion of Taiwan the center for
strategic and International Studies
estimated America would run out of all
important long range anti-ship missiles
ready you know within how long not a
quarter not a year not a month within a
week so what is Janet Yellen talking
about and why is Ukraine preparing to
bury 1 and A5 million people when you're
only 37 million people living there who
knows we're going to talk about that
today okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let me give you
a couple timelines here on what's going
on January 19 2024 chairman of NATO's
military committee Admiral Rob Bower
said that although NATO and member
governments already in themselves for
conflict with Putin's regime civilians
must realize that they also have a role
to play this is January 19 2024 just
recently then January 21st Europe must
prepare for war with Russia military
expert warns they're not giving a name
who this person is they're just warning
hey can't tell you who I am Anonymous
but here's what you have to be ready for
this is January 21st then January 23rd
Ukraine spy Chief not even conceivable
that we can win without massive
mobilization not even conceivable that
they can win without massive
mobilization what does that really mean
let's take a look at Ukraine's current
military now keep this in mind what I
believe in is the the whole concept of
foga War which means both sides can give
you whatever stats they want to give you
you got to kind of try to check both of
the sides credibility and believe a
little bit of both sides and be paranoid
and questionable about both sides
whatever they may be saying they're
always going to say we have less people
that died and they have so many people
that have died every side wants to say
that so according to Colonel mcregor
there are thousands of wounded
ukrainians being left to die on the
battlefield growing number of Ukrainian
commanders and troups refusing orders to
conduct suicide attacks against heavily
fortified Russian positions Ukrainian
soldiers are surrendering in masses to
Russia hospitals overflowing with
Wounded Ukraine government plans to
radically increase the number of women
serving in the military and remember how
earlier I talked about the fact that
military Chronicle Ukrainian authorities
will soon be able to bury 1 and a half
million people watches the leader in the
growth of the territory was a cemetery
in chassi its area increased by 670
1,000 square m just to be able to bury
potentially 1 and A5 million people why
are they doing that According to rusi
which would sound like a Russia think
tank it's actually not a Russian Think
Tank the Royal United Services Institute
which if you want to know a little bit
more about these guys is a defense and
security Think Tank headquartered in
London UK and it was founded in 1831 by
the Duke of Wellington Arthur Wellesley
so there is no benefit for them
defending Russia but watch what they say
Russia's getting stronger and Europe's
getting weaker Russia's military supply
situation has been steadily improving
its factories are standardizing around
fewer type of Tanks artillery haers and
uavs resulting in steadily Rising
production figures from around 40 long
range missiles per month at the start of
the invasion Russia is now producing 100
missiles per month artillery ammunition
production has almost doubled recently
supplemented by over 1 million shells
and hundreds of howitzers from North
Korea Factory iies have also been set up
in Iran to add resilience and additional
capacity to Russia's rearmament drive
after the vast losses in material and
ammunition expenditure of the past 18
months of War Russia is preparing for a
long War aiming to grind down Ukraine
and exhaust the capacity and will of its
Western supporters to supply the
vehicles ammunition and weapons it needs
to keep fighting successfully Russia's
government has announced plans for a 68%
increase in defense spending to 65% of
GDP next year during the Cold War Soviet
spending on defense was Far higher than
this reaching 21% of GDP by 1985 and
still took decades to arguably bring
about the collapse of USSR so so an
independent think tank from UK that's
been around since 1831 is saying
Russia's getting stronger Europe's
getting weaker Ukraine's getting weaker
why would they say such a thing like
this well let's let's take a look at
Europe to see how Europe's in European
industrial capacity for weapon
production eroded after the cold world
European nations Limited stock poils and
productions for a to Ukraine EU
struggling to supply 1 million artillery
shells to Ukraine us 70% of NATO's
defense spending in 2022 and eu's
defending spending up 20% the past
decade Russia China up
3600% EU is up 20% in the last decade
Russia's up 300 China's up 600 British
military highest rated European military
ranks below Russia China and India only
150 Deployable tanks 12 long range
artillery pieces let's look at France
second highest rated European power
ranked below South Korea Pakistan and
Japan 90 Heavy Artillery pieces Denmark
no heavy artillery submarines air
defense systems German military look how
powerful they used to be compared to
what they are today at the end of Cold
War they had 500,000 soldiers in West
Germany 300,000 in East Germany West
Germany alone had more than 7,000 battle
tanks by the 1980s today only 180,000
personnel and they went from 7 ,000
tanks to 200 tanks only half of which
are likely operational according to
government officials the country's
industry can make only about three tanks
a month that's 36 a year these officials
said Germany's army has enough
ammunition for two days of battle that's
what Germany's got two days of battle
Germany was feared years ago today no
one fears Germany two days of battle is
what they got Netherlands last tank unit
disabled in 2011 that's 13 years ago
Poland plans to spend more than 4% of
its annual economic output on defense
and 2024 almost double what it did in
2024 Poland could have the strongest
conventional forces in Europe in 2 or 3
years said Ben nemed the academic
program director the advanced Command
Staff course at the defense Academy of
the UK the country's top postgraduate
military program to there's a couple
things here to keep in mind number one
fog award nobody knows what's going on
even the stats I gave you you don't know
100% I don't know 100% I'm simply giving
you the numbers based on what somebody
else got and those people got it from
somebody on the inside that may be given
the information based on some motive
nobody knows however let's assume what
we're reading here is correct if it is
correct what's the difference between EU
Russia and US here's what's the
difference Russia has their own military
industrial complex they produce weapons
they don't need to rely on the companies
that we use they do their own thing and
they have other allies that also hate
America and NATO that are helping
Ukraine such as Iran and China so if
they need to lean on somebody they got
plenty of people go to EU since they
started what they're doing with the NATO
what what has happened to EU theyve all
Saturn guys we don't need to spend all
this money into our military we don't
need to put that money into our budget
you know why why America let those
idiots spend the money and they'll
protect us we don't need to spend it let
them pay more of it what are you doing
he guys put money you know it's kind of
like a person goes to a restaurant and
you're out with people and everybody
knows you're the rich one and everyone
goes like this don't reach your pocket
let him you know it's like time
everybody you've eaten dessert
everything's over with and everybody
goes like this oh America touched the
wallet okay great fantastic awesome this
is so great that's all they're doing
they know you us is going to reach their
pocket to pay the most for what because
of USSR back in the days and that's why
we started it why don't you guys
strengthen your military Germany why
don't you strengthen your military
France why don't you strengthen your
military UK why don't you guys
strengthen your military why are you
relying on America to do this for you
now us has room military-industrial
complex but just because you got money
and Janet D said oh we can handle both
don't worry we got all the money this is
where money doesn't matter imagine when
War breaks out and there's a Civil War
and everybody's killing each other in a
city and a billionaire comes on and says
guys I'm a billionaire how much money do
you need the guy said I don't give a
about your money I need guns what
do you have I don't have any guns but I
got billions no one cares about your
money during a civil war they care if
you have weapons and Janet Yellen saying
we got money don't worry there are no
weapons to buy Janet Yellen it takes
years to build them that is a problem
when we're going out saying yeah let's
give them some tanks yeah yeah yeah take
some of these missiles no no America's
getting weak when we do this because
we're worried about EU and all these
other guys very problem atic I'm a
little bit too paranoid on this topic
and I think you need to be as well
because nobody has all the information
mainstream's telling us one thing we
don't really know what's going on the
foga War I think is really effective in
effect with specifically to Ukraine and
Russia War if you got Val add in this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel if you want to learn more
about this topic specifically NATO like
what's the history behind NATO click
here to watch this video you're going to
learn a lot about NATO take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye
a